the leader
the only player in all three events
still perfect after four rounds
congratulations sophie welcome back to
the show how did you live this game
i feel great
um
yeah i
i'm really proud of myself i guess
you played this uh grunfeld inviting a
fight
was that a strategy early on
yeah
i'm just it's
it's really early so i'm just trying to
play for a win every round
every single game white or black doesn't
matter and
you guys uh ended up in this position
knight to d7 bishop f4 did she surprise
you by the way with this early h3 was
that the line that he looked at or was
that a surprise didn't look at that um i
looked at bishop e2
i did not look at h3 but i thought i
could just kind of go with the same
ideas
absolutely and you did let's keep going
bishop to f4
and this was the moment let's keep going
for a few more
d5 queen to a4
what what were your feelings when you
saw this move land on the board queen to
b1
um well i was surprised i
like when i was thinking about queen a4
i
or when i was i mean queen of four was
like my idea in this position anyway um
of course i need to calculate some
things um
but i'm pretty sure the only move for
white is like yeah queen b5 or queen b3
i'm pretty sure one of those is forced
correct i um
looked at i mean i saw
it registered in my mind that queen b1
was a possibility
but i really wasn't expecting it to be
played um i actually didn't see knight
takes d5 like when i was calculating it
when i was thinking about queen a4 but i
only saw it after like why i actually
played queen v1
so that was um a nice surprise how long
did it take you to see to spot the move
knight to d5 i think i saw it like
almost immediately
and then you spent a few minutes to
double check yeah make sure you're not
missing anything and after that
how close did you feel like here uh in
this endgame from victory
um
not until like i was up two pawns like i
thought it was pretty tough up until
like i
i don't i i don't really know what
happened around here but i ended up
winning like a second pawn
with f after f5 even here i wasn't
really sure what was happening but i
think it was like i think i really
registered that i was like winning on
when i like played f4 and f3 finally
exchanged double pawns now it's a clean
two
pawns well
and after that a clinical
uh victory and uh conversion
in this winning end game sophie
was there to say four out of four just a
brilliant performance up to this point
how do you feel right now
you must be in cloud nine
yeah um i feel pretty amazing
is this the best start that you've had
in a tournament
yeah i think like um the second best
start that i've had in a major
tournament was like
three and a half out of four so this is
new for me
[Music]
well
big congratulations guys any questions
no whatever it is you're doing keep it
up because it's one of them it's working
four out of four we're going to call you
miss perfect keep it going
you can't say anything against
perfection and there we have the
head-to-head alice lee
disappointing event for her
what can we say we had great hopes for
her after the american cup
she wow